it's a full-blown battle over
impeachment playing out in Washington DC
president Trump blasting Democrats for
their latest conspiratorial attacks he
was supposed to meet with Chuck Schumer
at Nancy Pelosi this morning to talk
about infrastructure but right before
Pelosi said this it was a very positive
meeting of a respectful sharing of ideas
would you believe that it's important
for the to follow the facts we believe
that no one is above the law
including the President of the United
States and we believe that the President
of the United States is engaged in a
cover-up in a cover-up
and that recreation after that stunt
Trump decided to blow up the meeting by
calling out Schumer and Pelosi to their
faces and walked away he then headed to
the Rose Garden equipped with a classic
Trump visual where he laid into
Democrats all of a sudden I hear last
night they're gonna have a meeting right
before this meeting to talk about the
i-word the i-word instead of walking in
happily into a meeting I walk in to look
at people that had just said that I was
doing a cover-up I don't do cover-ups
I told Senator Schumer speaker Pelosi I
want to do infrastructure but you know
what you can't do it under these
circumstances so get these phony
investigations over with Schumer and
Pelosi responding by trying to spin the
meeting to watch what happened in the
White House would make your jaw drop I
was prepared to give him a 35-page plan
we were interested we are interested in
doing infrastructure it's clear the
president isn't but this was not a
spontaneous move on the president's part
it was planned the president wasn't
having it he fired right back tweeting
the Democrats are tearing the punk
country apart
but of course Pelosi has since doubled
down on her cover-up comment and claims
it could be an impeachable offense all
right Dana it's pretty clear to the
country that Nancy and Chuck cannot work
with the president so far they've shut
down the government
no border security no infrastructure
investigations it's a mess I said the
Democrats I'm trying to think of like
what is the what is the good news that
they could point to in January that they
have caused right is there anything that
that has gone their way not really
okay and now they might be able to spend
a couple things but they might say about
the president's poll numbers are still
down however the president can say well
I might not be able to get a lot done
with Congress but I'll things I have
done that are under my control I've been
able to execute on and look at our
economy look at all he could come we
have the list we can go through the list
I think the thing about her Nancy Pelosi
is she's super strategic mhm
we know she's very wise she's very good
at politics she didn't just say cover up
as like an offhand remark this was with
deliberate intention because she's under
the pressure from grassroots she was
forced to say well it's also it's very
it gets under his skin right she loves
to get him riled up so that then she can
say oh my gosh he would not have
believed the reaction it was just
overwhelming and I have to have to pray
for him and but her caucus wants
infrastructure and impeachment she
didn't want you know that's that is true
what I also like about this idea is I'm
just picturing it there in the Cabinet
Room the president walking in not
sitting down right like yeah this
stuff's over yeah like we're not doing
this and if you think back to when his
supporters would say in the primary
elections when he was beating all the
Republicans what do you like about him
and they would say well he tells it like
it is this is a it was a charade to
think one that infrastructure was gonna
get done anyway they're so far apart a
35-page plan does it work for anybody
nobody needs a 35-page plan he needs a
1-page plan to see if they could do it
so that was a charade it wasn't going to
happen the president's basically let's
just stop pretending that you just that
you are here to help get me impeached
but to pretend like you are actually
wanting to work on things and he said
I'm not gonna do it anymore why would
you negotiate Greg when someone has a
knife to your throat this was a great
example of when politics clashes with
business alright it what what what nancy
instructed was planned and it was
political and i would be pissed off too
it'd be like dana coming before the five
and just announcing that she burned my
house down now let's go to the
you don't do that and so it's different
when you're in business no one before a
meeting would accuse you of being a
criminal right but in politics there is
no such limitations they'll call you a
criminal a war criminal and then they'll
have lunch with you and then when they
said well clearly he doesn't want
infrastructure how stupid do you think
the American public is he was pissed off
because of what you did it had he wants
infrastructure he's been doing
infrastructure of his entire life I do
love the fact that he brought visuals
that means you know he's incorporating
Fox graphics into his display intros
Peter
Trump's poll numbers might be down but
when you ask Americans what kind of job
he's doing and if they are better off
they're way high how stupid you have to
be to see how this plays out
impeachment fails Trump is a folk hero
impeachment impeachment succeeds he's a
folk hero and you have Pence's president
and you have Trump going around he's not
going anywhere
you're gonna have two Republican
presidents and everybody who push the
hysteria will be a laughingstock because
they're not gonna real they're not going
to like Bernie Sanders after this you're
gonna have 75 million people who are
pissed off and they're gonna really like
pence it's getting you the point is note
the pendulum swings the more you jump
over the more you push the more they
push back and that's what you're going
to see with brexit that's what you're
seeing right now with Faraj people are
going after him and it's just gonna
create more fans what do you think
happened today well I just I'm so amazed
to listen because it seems to me Trump
did a big stunt in which he didn't know
how to pay for infrastructure that's
what's going on in Washington last time
that he was engaged in a new
conversation with Democrats about
infrastructure he got in trouble with
fellow Republicans who said hey hold on
mr. president we're not raising taxes
we're not talking about a gas tax we're
not talking about repealing any of the
tax cuts that you put in place on
Popular's they may be but guess what if
you are serious about infrastructure and
the president is last meeting with the
Democrats and two trillion trillion
dollars you have to find the money
somewhere the revenue has to come from
somewhere and he doesn't know where to
get the money but you thought
you boys here so vataj the meeting below
he didn't know where the money was
coming from salutely doesn't care about
where the money's coming from somebody
has to kiss somebody has to govern the
country and if you want what you talk
about pre-plan what was pre-planned was
his rose garden ceremony before they
even got to the White House sign out
maybe that Pelosi was the one who
miscalculated because she was forced by
her caucus to say something aggressive
she miscalculated accused the president
of a criminal cover-up and now the
American people you don't have the
infrastructure that they want are you
kidding me she's not responsible first
of all what a crazy thing he said when
he said nothing will get done until
these investigation well that means
guess what mr. president the
investigations are not going to stop so
you're saying the country is not going
to block govern we had two years Bill
Clinton was being impeached and he
worked on the s chip bill in terms of
helping young people get his approval
numbers went up he's not going to do
anything
the Democrats are hustle are coming out
calmly but are so transparent that they
are willing to sabotage their own
purported interests or the interests of
their constituents rather than give
Trump an inch not even a victory just an
inch and what I mean by that is it was
so obvious that yes this is a charade
yes this was planned yes this was
strategy of course it was Pelosi tossing
a lit match on to the bundle of cinder
that is Trump when she says there's a
cover-up and has these buzzwords of
course he's gonna freak out so it was so
transparent to people like us and the
worst part is that infrastructure is
bipartisan and the money is absolutely
there when there's projected 312
trillion in audits uncovered in the
government in terms of like slashing
spending the money is absolutely there
that's not the issue the issue is that
these guys are putting the deal before
themselves in terms of what it
represents
like if Schumer implosive were actually
interested in infrastructure they
wouldn't have pulled this stunt and
Schumer it was like the Nicene Creed we
even this and we believe in this like
the whole thing is such a farce from top
to bottom
you think there's money you think
there's money sitting there but I don't
think the president's that want it's not
about money it's not about money they're
accusing the president of covering up a
crime that never happened the Russian
interference never happened that's oh I
love how he's shifted that he said
Russian interference
he didn't say collusion he already blew
I love the use of the phrase cover-up on
the same day the investigation into the
George the Virginia Governor Northrup
who may or may not have been covered up
in blackface that's the cover-up